I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hello.
I just want to tell you something.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正为你打造终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量闺蜜故事，带你更深入地了解《办公室》的世界。我们是《办公室女士》6.0。你好。我只是想告诉你一件事。
I'm not sure if you realize this.
It looks like you still have an imprint of maybe your pillowcase.
Did you sleep really hard last night?
Yes, I did.
I mean, I know you were tired because you were texting me at like almost 11 o'clock,
which is so late for you.
So late for me.
I was in bed, lights off.
我不知道你有没有注意到。看起来你脸上好像还印着枕套的痕迹。你昨晚睡得很死吗？是的，我睡得很死。我是说，我知道你很累，因为你在将近11点的时候还给我发信息，对你来说这太晚了。对我也太晚了。我当时在床上，灯都关了。
I'm like, what's happening?
What's Jenna?
That's a role reversal.
I know, right?
That never happens.
You're the late night texter.
Well, you know, everybody, you're going to be listening to this in July.
Hi, July.
我在想，发生什么事了？珍娜怎么了？这可是角色对调。我知道，对吧？这从来没发生过。你才是那个深夜发信息的人。好吧，你们知道的，大家听到这期节目的时候已经是七月了。嗨，七月。
But we're recording this back in June.
And it's the last week of school for our kids.
Exactly.
You know how that is.
Yeah.
And last night was the sixth grade graduation party.
At my kid's school, they do a sixth grade graduation and a 12th grade graduation.
嗨，七月。但我们是在六月录音的。这是我们孩子们开学的最后一周。确实。你们懂得那种感受。对。昨晚是六年级毕业派对。在我孩子的学校，他们有六年级毕业典礼和十二年级毕业典礼。
So elementary school is K through sixth.
Same.
Yeah.
Eighth grade gets nothing.
That's right.
Sorry, eighth grade.
You know, my sister's kids, they go K through eighth.
So they have a big eighth grade graduation.
所以小学是从学前班到六年级。一样。对。八年级什么都没有。没错。抱歉了，八年级。你知道的，我姐姐的孩子们，他们是从学前班到八年级。所以他们有一个盛大的八年级毕业典礼。
Right, right.
We have sixth grade and twelfth grade.
Yeah.
And let me tell you who parties hard.
It is.
Sixth grade moms who made it through elementary school.
God bless you, six grade moms.
This one mom, oh my gosh, we're so grateful to her.
对，对。我们有六年级和十二年级。对。让我告诉你谁才是派对之王。就是熬过小学的六年级妈妈们。上帝保佑你们，六年级妈妈们。有个妈妈，天哪，我们太感激她了。
She opened up her house, her backyard.
She had all the families there.
So it was like, I mean, I don't even know how many people that was.
Oh, I always worry about the bathrooms.
That's a lot of people using your bathroom.
Yeah, it is.
Sorry, I didn't mean to get off on that.
Continue.
她敞开了自己的家，她的后院。她把所有家庭都请去了。所以那场面，我是说，我都不知道到底有多少人。哦，我总是担心洗手间的问题。那么多人用你的洗手间。对，是的。抱歉，我不是故意扯到这个话题的。继续。
But they put out a dance floor on the lawn and there was a DJ.
And there were a set of songs that were
clearly for the moms. Like the kids cleared off the floor. Wait. Wait. I'm track and run DMC.
I was going to say, you know, it was like a good time. Can I tell you at ours, the one that all the moms
showed up for was, come on, Eileen. It was such a moment in time. Yes, yes. But there was this one part
where the DJ's like, all right, get down low, get down low. And I got down low. But did you get back up?
This, I did not plan ahead.
I did get up.
但他们在草坪上铺了一个舞池，还有一个DJ。有一组歌显然是专门放给妈妈们的。就像孩子们都从舞池里退开了。等等。等等。我追随Run DMC。我本想说，你知道的，那真是一段美好的时光。我能告诉你吗，在我们的派对上，所有妈妈都涌上舞池的那首歌是《Come On Eileen》。那真是个难忘的时刻。是的，是的。但有一个环节，DJ说：“好啦，蹲低点，蹲低点。”然后我就蹲低了。但你站起来了吗？这个嘛，我没有提前计划。我确实站起来了。
I did, but it was real, like, creaky and slow.
But all of that is to say, yeah, I mean, I got home at 10.30, that's not even late.
But I was so fired up.
I couldn't fall asleep until, like, one.
So I'm hard today.
I think getting home at 10.30 is late.
I mean, I usually go to bed at 9 o'clock.
I know.
我站起来了，但过程真的很像吱呀作响，非常缓慢。不过所有这些都是为了说明，好吧，我是说，我10点半到家，这甚至都不算晚。但我太兴奋了。我直到一点左右才睡着。所以我今天状态很差。我觉得10点半到家已经很晚了。我是说，我通常9点钟睡觉。我知道。
I know, because now I don't text you after 9.
Yeah.
Because I know she tie-tie.
I mean, I'm grouchy if you text me at 8 because I'm like, do not fire up my brain.
I won't make it.
She's not going to make it.
Anyway, sorry, that got me so tickled.
We have such a fun episode today, guys.
我知道，因为现在我9点以后就不给你发信息了。对。因为我知道你“钛”累了（taita/困了）。我是说，如果你8点给我发信息，我会很不高兴，因为我在想，别刺激我的大脑。我撑不住了。她撑不住的。总之，抱歉，那把我逗得太开心了。伙计们，我们今天有一期非常有趣的节目。
We do.
I mean, like, I'm really excited about it.
I'm really excited.
And it was a absolute blast to revisit this.
Today's episode was inspired by us finding our stress relief part two candy bag alts for
Michael's roast.
We're calling this one.
Boom roasted.
确实。我是说，我真的为之兴奋。我真的很激动。重温这一集绝对是一场狂欢。今天的节目的灵感来自于我们为迈克尔的吐槽大会寻找《压力救济》第二部分糖果袋备选台词。我们把这一集叫做：“轰，被吐槽了吧。”
You guys will not believe
how much was in the candy bag alts
for this episode.
I just want to loop you in.
Are you ready for this?
I'm going to throw some numbers at you.
Great.
轰，被吐槽了吧。你们绝对不会相信这一集的糖果袋备选台词里有多少内容。我只想带你了解一下。准备好听这个了吗？我要抛出一堆数字给你。好极了。
The overall stress relief main candy bag document
was 320 pages.
The candy bags,
just for the scenes and talking heads
for the roast,
is 207 pages.
And the candy bags just solely
for alternate roast jokes
《压力救济》主糖果袋文档共有320页。仅仅是为吐槽大会的场景和单人访谈准备的糖果袋就有207页。而仅用于备选吐槽笑话的糖果袋
is 40 pages.
I mean, that is so nuts.
It is nuts.
Well, we thought it would be fun to dig into those.
And we also watched the superfan episode of Stress Relief Part 2.
And I found this Jim Talking Head that was added back to the episode.
And in this talking head, Jim is kind of summing up how he thinks their roast is going to go.
And I think it's also going to apply to our podcast.
就有40页。我的天，这太疯狂了。简直疯狂。好吧，我们觉得深入研究这些内容会很有趣。而且我们还观看了《压力救济》第二部分的超级粉丝加长版。我找到了这段加回到剧集中的吉姆单人访谈。在这个单人访谈中，吉姆总结了他认为他们的吐槽大会将会如何进行。我想这也适用于我们的播客。
Let's hear it.
To quote Michael, this will be like shooting fish in a barbell.
Yeah.
Fish in a barbell.
That's one of Michael's mangleds.
Exactly.
我们来听听看。借用迈克尔的话来说，这就像在杠铃里打鱼一样。对。杠铃里的鱼。杠铃里的鱼。那是迈克尔的经典口误之一。没错。没错。
This episode I feel like is going to be like shooting fish in a barrel because we have read
these candy bag alts and they are so great.
But also there is a good chance we're going to mangle something because I am very
tired and you are you.
And so it might be like shooting fish in a box.
Excuse me?
You get a pass for being tired and I just walk in every day, a fucking hot mess.
How dare you?
我觉得这一集就像是在木桶里打鱼一样简单，因为我们读过这些糖果袋备选台词，它们太棒了。但同时，我们很有可能会口误，因为我很累，而你就是你。所以这可能就像在一个盒子里打鱼。不好意思？你因为累而获得了一张通行证，而我每天走进门，都是个他妈的一团糟。你怎么敢？
I know exactly what you met by that too.
Sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm so tired.
You too, too, I'm sorry.
So when Jenna's tired, you get the truth serum.
I have no edit button today.
I'm too tired.
Okay.
我也完全知道你刚才那个词是什么意思。抱歉。对不起，我太累了。你也是，也是，对不起。所以当珍娜累了的时候，你就会听到诚实药水。我今天没有编辑按钮。我太累了。好吧。
But don't you think?
No, I'm not going to label myself an everyday hot mess.
No, not a hot mess, but a mangled worder.
Oh, yes, yes.
See?
Yes.
A mangled worder.
但是你不觉得吗？不，我不会给自己贴上每天都一团糟的标签。不，不是一团糟，而是一个口误大王。哦，对，对。看到了吧？没错。没错。一个口误大王。
That's right.
I might mangle some words today because I'm really tired.
And you might mangle some words today because you are you.
Right.
That's just an Angela Kinsey.
Just an Angela special.
Okay, fine.
没错。我今天可能会说错一些词，因为我真的很累。而你今天可能会说错一些词，因为你就是你。对。这就是安吉拉·金斯利式的风格。纯粹的安吉拉特色。好吧，好吧。好吧，好吧。
Now I see where you were going.
You saw where I was going.
Okay.
All right.
But first, oh, speaking of sleeping, our chit-chat suggestion.
It's coming in from Lily D in Mobile, Alabama.
Let's hear it.
Hi, office ladies.
现在我明白你的意思了。你明白我的意思了。好吧。好吧。但首先，哦，说到睡觉，我们的闲聊建议。它来自阿拉巴马州莫尔比的莉莉·D。我们来听听看。嗨，办公室女士们。
My name is Lily.
I'm from Mobile, Alabama.
And my question for you today is, do you sleep in silence or do you sleep with white noise?
I'm a youth minister.
And recently, I had an overnight event with my students.
And they made so much fun of me for listening to white noise.
And so I'm curious if you sleep in silence or with white noise.
thank you guys so much for taking the time to answer my question. And I just want to say I've been a listener from the very beginning and I just love you guys so much. Thank you. Lily, thank you so much. We love your right back. Lily, did you get any sleep that night when you did that sleepover? I mean, I've done a youth retreat. I mean, when I was younger, it can be a little bit of mayhem. Well, I always wonder, how are the adults sleeping, like on these field trips and on these like sleepover events?
我叫莉莉。我来自阿拉巴马州莫尔比。我今天给你们的问题是：你们睡觉时保持安静，还是伴着白噪音入眠？我是一名青年牧师。最近，我和我的学生们一起参加了一场过夜活动。他们因为我听白噪音而狠狠地嘲笑了我。所以我很好奇你们是喜欢在安静中入眠，还是伴着白噪音。非常感谢你们抽出时间回答我的问题。我只想说，我从一开始就是你们的听众，我真的超级爱你们。谢谢。莉莉，非常感谢你。我们也同样爱着你。莉莉，你那天晚上举行留宿活动时睡着了吗？我是说，我参加过青年静修营。我的意思是，自我年轻时起，那地方就有点像个混乱的战场。好吧，我总是纳闷，大人们在这些实地考察和留宿活动中是怎么睡觉的？
I know, especially if you're in a room with a bunch of bunks and a bunch of kids all like hopped up.
Exactly.
Just excitement because they're away.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
I mean, I know my answer to this guys right away.
Well, yeah, I know mine too.
I need silence.
我知道，特别是如果你和一个满屋子双层床、满屋子兴奋过头的孩子住在一起。没错。只有兴奋，因为他们离家在外。嗯哼。对。我是说，伙计们，我马上就知道我的答案是什么了。好吧，是的，我也知道我的。我需要安静。
Silence.
I one time was like, no white noise.
No white noise.
And it's a little tricky because Josh needs green noise.
What's green noise?
I don't know what's an app he has.
It's like green noise.
安静。安静。我曾经说过，不要白噪音。不要白噪音。这有点棘手，因为乔什需要绿噪音。什么是绿噪音？我不知道，那是他用的一个应用程序。就像绿噪音。
And so green noise.
I've never heard of.
You're nodding.
What is green noise?
Green noise.
Okay, I believe, because I listen to 432 hertz, which is the delta brainwaves.
It's the hertz that your brainwaves function on for eight hours on YouTube.
That's what I sleep to.
所以是绿噪音。我从来没听说过。你在点头。什么是绿噪音？绿噪音。好吧，我相信，因为我听432赫兹，那是德尔塔脑波。那是YouTube上你的大脑以其运行八小时的赫兹。那就是伴我入眠的声音。
Whoa.
I think green noise is similar to that.
Okay.
Well, I hadn't heard of it, but he, like, read up on, like, because he went through a phase
where he just was having some insomnia.
Mm-hmm.
So this green noise, he plays it.
And I can't really hear it.
哇。我觉得绿噪音和那个类似。好吧。嗯，我以前没听说过，但他，就像是研究过，因为他经历过一段时间的失眠。嗯哼。所以这个绿噪音，他会播放它。而我其实听不到。
it's fine.
Like, I don't even know what the sound is, but it doesn't really bother me.
But I kind of need to go to sleep before he turns it on.
Does that make sense?
And then it's playing and I'm fine.
Otherwise, I like silence.
And if I go to your house, if you're so nice and say, hey, Ange, you're visiting.
Here's my guest room.
这很好。就像我甚至不知道那是什么声音，但它真的不困扰我。不过我需要在他在打开它之前入眠。这说得通吗？然后它播放着，我很好。除此之外，我喜欢安静。如果我去了你家，如果你人很好，说：“嘿，安吉，你来做客。这是我的客房。”
I'm going to have to walk through that guest room.
And I'm going to have to look for any lights.
If you have like an outlet that has a little green flashy light, I'm going to be covering it with something.
Yep.
And then if you have like,
a cute little alarm clock that has a little...
My parents have that in both of their guest rooms.
I have to unplug it or take the batteries out.
我将不得不走进那间客房。我得检查有没有任何灯光。如果你有一个带着微弱闪烁绿光的插座，我会用东西把它盖上。没错。然后如果你有一个可爱的小闹钟，上面有一个小……我父母的两间客房里都有那个。我必须拔掉它或者把电池取出来。
Same.
I feel bad because the last time I was at my parents' house,
I went into the guest bedroom to, like, lay down and take a nap.
Yeah.
And I hid the clock, the ticking clock, like under the bed and I forgot to put it back.
They're probably like, where's my bedside clock?
I've done that.
I've like rolled it up and like a sheet and put it in a drawer.
一样。我感到很抱歉，因为上次我在我父母家时，我走进客房，想要躺下来打个盹。对。然后我把那个闹钟，那个滴答作响的时钟，藏在床底下，结果我忘了把它放回去了。他们大概在想，我的床头钟呢？我做过那种事。我把它卷在床单里，然后塞进了一个抽屉。
Exactly.
Okay.
So yeah, I need silence.
I do like to sleep with a window open, though.
So whatever's going on outside just kind of becomes like my white noise, I think.
Like whatever, you know, birds chirping.
Sam, can you play some of this green noise for us?
I absolutely can.
没错。好吧。所以是的，我需要安静。不过我确实喜欢开着窗户睡觉。所以外面发生的任何声音不知怎么的都成了我的白噪音，我想。就像无论什么，你知道的，鸟儿的啁啾声。萨姆，你能给我们放一点这种绿噪音吗？我完全可以。
Okay.
Oh, my God.
My body is having a response to this sound.
In a good way?
In a good way.
Like I...
So it's supposed...
This is 250 hertz, which is supposed to be calming and relieving.
好的。哦，天哪。我的身体对这个声音有反应了。以一种好的方式？以一种好的方式。就像我……所以它应该……这是250赫兹，据说能让人平静和放松。
Oh my God.
Am I in a womb?
Am I on a plane?
To me, it's like I either am hearing the ocean or I'm on a plane.
That's interesting.
You say the womb, that's what it's supposed to emulate the sound of like blight around you and being inside the womb.
We're in a womb.
Cozy.
哦，天哪。我在子宫里吗？我在飞机上吗？对我来说，要么像是在听大海的声音，要么我是在飞机上。这很有趣。你说在子宫里，那就是它旨在模拟的声音，就像你周围的温和声音以及在子宫里的感觉。我们在子宫里。真舒服。
That's what we're recording from today.
Wow.
Okay.
Interesting.
Maybe I'll try it.
Yeah.
Well, my answer is that I need a lot of things to sleep.
I need white noise.
这就是我们今天录音的地方。哇。好吧。有趣。也许我会试试。好吧，我的回答是，我需要很多东西才能入眠。我需要白噪音。
This is not surprising.
The lady loves a list.
I need white noise.
I need blackout curtains.
This was my favorite thing about Japan was that the curtains in all the hotel rooms
overlapped.
They didn't just stop when they got to the middle and then you had to pile pillows up so that you didn't have something seeping through.
You would really like Iceland because they get so much daylight at different times of the year that they do not mess around.
这并不令人意外。这位女士热爱列清单。我需要白噪音。我需要遮光窗帘。我在日本最喜欢的事情就是所有酒店房间的窗帘都是重叠的。当它们拉到中间时不会刚好停下，然后你还得把枕头堆起来，以免有什么光透进来。你会非常喜欢冰岛，因为他们一年中不同时期的白昼太长了，所以他们在窗帘这件事上绝不含糊。
With their curtains.
Yeah.
So I need blackout curtains.
I don't understand people who like just.
have like sort of sheer curtains on their windows?
I don't understand it.
It's confusing to me.
对他们的窗帘。对。对。所以我需要遮光窗帘。我不理解那些喜欢……在窗户上挂那种薄纱窗帘的人？我不理解。这让我感到困惑。
In a bedroom.
Fine.
You want to have them in like a living room so you get some light.
Can I ask what temperature you require your bedroom to be?
71 degrees.
Okay.
I like my bedroom cold.
在卧室里。好吧。好吧。你可能想在客厅里挂那种，这样能透进一些光。请问你对卧室的温度有什么要求？71华氏度。好吧。我喜欢我的卧室冷一点。
I know.
Same here.
Cold and cold with lots of blankets is the correct answer, right?
Me too.
Like a weighted blanket.
Yes.
So I definitely sleep with white noise lily.
I also sleep with an eye.
我知道。我也是。又冷又盖着很多毯子，这才是正确的答案，对吧？我也是。就像一条重力毯。是的。所以莉莉，我绝对是伴着白噪音睡觉的。我睡觉时还会戴上眼罩。
mask on just in case we have any failure of said curtains. I also sleep with special earplugs
that I did a bunch of research about and they are actually phenomenal. I read them on like a
Christmas list for things to get people who are hard to shop for and I bought them for myself.
And I love them and a fan. I have to have a fan blowing on me for my hot flashes. We have traveled
together many times now over these years. And one of my favorite things is I forget where we were,
but we had a hotel room that had the little connectie door.
Yeah.
And I was like fully showered, had done my hair, was doing my makeup,
以防上述窗帘有任何失效的情况。我睡觉时还会戴上我做过很多研究的特殊耳塞，它们实际上好得惊人。我在一份给那些很难挑礼物的人准备的圣诞礼物清单上看到了它们，然后我给自己买了一副。我超爱它们，还有风扇。为了对付我的潮热，我必须让风扇对着我吹。这些年来，我们现在一起旅行过很多次了。我最喜欢的事情之一就是，我忘了我们在哪里，但我们有一个带有小连接门的酒店房间。对。然后我洗完澡，做好了头发，正在化着妆，
and you came through the connectie door with your eye mask on your forehead.
I think one of your earplugs in your hand, very discombobulated because you had
overslept your alarm.
And I was almost ready to walk out the door.
You're like, but I would think, lady, how do you hear your alarm?
I hear it.
You hear it through the ear plugs and the noise and all the things.
Yeah. Okay. Well, well, you did it in that morning. I guess not. Lily, I love that question. I love these little slice of live shares. I think they're so fun.
你额头上戴着眼罩，手里拿着一个耳塞，从连接门走了过来，整个人非常晕头转向，因为你的闹钟睡过头了。而我当时已经准备好出门了。你说：“但我想，女士，你怎么能听到你的闹钟呢？”我听得到的。你透过耳塞、噪音和所有这些东西还是能听到它。好吧。好吧，那天早上你确实听到了。我想没有吧。莉莉，我很喜欢那个问题。我喜欢这些生活切片分享。我觉得它们太有趣了。
I love our new format for Office Ladies. I was thinking about it and just how much I love it because of how much it involves getting to hear from people.
Yes. It's sort of a call back to the very beginning of Office Ladies where people would call in and read the summary, remember? Oh, yeah. And we loved that.
We did. So here we are.
Well, listen, we're going to take a break, and then we are going to get into Boom Roasted.
Well, we are back, and before we dig into all of the additional roasting from this episode,
I want us to remember Michael's expectations for this roast.
Yeah.
Because he has a lot of expectations for how the roast is going to go.
我喜欢我们《办公室女士》的新形式。我一直在思考它，以及我是多么喜欢它，因为这包含了能听到大家的心声。是的。这有点像是《办公室女士》最初的回溯，当时人们会打电话进来朗读总结，还记得吗？哦，是的。我们很喜欢那样。我们确实很喜欢。所以我们来了。好吧，听着，我们要休息一下，然后我们要进入“轰，被吐槽了吧”。好吧，我们回来了，在我们深入探讨这一集的更多吐槽内容之前，我想让我们回想一下迈克尔对这次吐槽大会的期望。对。因为他对吐槽大会将如何进行有着很高的期望。
In rewatching this episode, I was so excited to find that there was an extended scene between Michael and Daryl.
You might remember, before the roast, he goes down to the warehouse,
to talk to Daryl.
He wants to talk about
what is the stage
going to look like?
What kind of chair
is he going to have?
在重温这一集时，我非常高兴地发现迈克尔和达里尔之间有一个加长场景。你可能还记得，在吐槽大会之前，他走到仓库去找达里尔谈话。他想谈谈舞台会是什么样子？他会坐什么样的椅子？
It's this amazing scene
and it was all expanded
for the super fan.
I think we need to hear it.
So that's the stage.
Yes.
All right, yeah.
You know, that'll work.
这是一个非常精彩的场景，而且为了超级粉丝加长版，这一切都扩展了。我觉得我们需要听听看。所以这就是舞台。对。好吧，行。
That'll work for my roast.
Supposed to be working as a warehouse.
Well, this is all about morale,
Daryl.
I will need a big chair,
a comfy chair,
like a throne for the
man of honor.
这对我的吐槽大会来说行得通。这里本该是工作仓库。好吧，这全关乎士气，达里尔。我需要一把大椅子，一把舒服的椅子，就像为荣誉嘉宾准备的宝座一样。
And I think all the other roasters should be up here on stage as well.
Everyone's on the stage?
Yeah, like a Comedy Central roast.
Who's in the audience?
The audience will be in the audience.
We'll charge $10 a head.
Charge who?
We'll need alcohol because that's very important for a roast.
而且我认为所有其他的吐槽者也应该在舞台上。所有人都上台？对，就像喜剧中心的吐槽大会那样。谁在观众席？观众就在观众席里。我们每人收10美元。收谁的钱？我们需要酒精，因为这对吐槽大会非常重要。
You need to get people drunk.
And you need something to spit.
You're going to be spitting in here?
Spit takes, yes.
I'll be doing some spit takes.
If it's funny enough, or I will do finger guns or, right?
Sammy Davis Jr. move, but you know that.
Or I will double over, or I will do the point.
你需要把人们灌醉。而且你需要一些可以吐口水的东西。你打算在这里吐口水吗？喜剧中的“呸”声动作，是的。我会做一些“呸”的动作。如果足够搞笑的话，或者我会做手枪手势，对吧？小萨米·戴维斯的动作，但你知道的。或者我会笑弯腰，或者我会做指点动作。
Like, oh, you got me.
What?
I got your big picture you wanted.
No, no, no, no.
I need a big picture.
Something cover the whole back of the dais.
I have to go to the printer.
We'll go, please.
就像，哦，你抓住我了。什么？我拿到了你想要的大照片。不，不，不，不。我需要一张大照片。要能遮住整个主席台后面的东西。我得去打印店。我们走，请吧。
Oh, and get me a drum and a symbol.
I want to do ba-dum-pumps.
Rim shots.
No, badump bumps.
Technical term is rim shots.
By the way, he was watching the roast.
He does all those things.
He does, obviously, the bad-dump, but he does finger guns.
哦，给我弄一个鼓和一个镲。我想发出“咚咚啪”的声音。Rim shots（边击声）。不，咚咚啪。专业术语叫Rim shots。顺便说一句，他在看吐槽大会的时候。他把那些动作都做了。他当然做了“咚咚啪”，但他还做了手枪手势。
He does them all.
Mm-hmm.
It's amazing.
I am really realizing, though, that but um-dumps.
Butop-dumps is something I'd probably say is making me think of like when we first started rewatching the office when I would call the shot through the blinds, the peep shot.
The peep shot.
And you're like, you mean the spy shot.
Well, it's just that we called it a spy shot.
他全都做了。嗯哼。太棒了。不过，我真的意识到，“咚咚啪”（butop-dumps）这个词，我可能会说出来，这让我想起当我们刚开始重温《办公室》时，我把透过百叶窗的偷窥镜头叫做 peep shot。Peep shot。而你说：“你是说 spy shot（间谍镜头）。”好吧，只是我们把它叫做 spy shot。
I know.
It's what I think the true term, not the peep shot.
All right, you guys, now it's time to dive into the candy bag alts.
Oh, it's so good.
We thought we would start right before the roast begins with some talking heads that really set the tone for how people in the office felt about the roast and how hard they were going to go at Michael.
I'm going to kick us off with a candy bag alt for Angela Martin.
Angela would have said, I wish I thought of writing down every problem I have with Michael for the last five years.
Angela pretends to find a notebook, which she holds up.
我知道。我想那是真正的术语，而不是 peep shot。好了，伙计们，现在是时候深入探讨糖果袋备选台词了。哦，太棒了。我们觉得可以从吐槽大会开始前不久的一些单人访谈切入，这些访谈真正为办公室里的人对吐槽大会的感受以及他们打算对迈克尔下多狠的手定下了基调。我先来念一个安吉拉·马丁的糖果袋备选台词。安吉拉会说：“我真希望自己能想到把过去五年里我对迈克尔的所有不满都写下来。”安吉拉假装找到一个笔记本，并把它举了起来。
Oh, wait a minute.
And she points to it.
She has been keeping a journal of every time Michael has pissed her off.
It's pretty amazing.
Well, Andy had some real gems, too.
Here is one of his talking heads.
Andy was going to say,
every now and then,
哦，等一下。她指着它。她一直在写日记，记录迈克尔惹恼她的每一次经历。这太惊人了。好吧，安迪也有一些真正的金句。这是他的其中一段单人访谈。安迪会说：偶尔，
you got to just take the gloves off and really rip into someone.
For the Bernards,
that's traditionally been on Thanksgiving.
So this will be a nice test run.
Can you imagine Thanksgiving at Andy Bernard's parents' house?
I cannot.
How many jabs they throw at him?
Oh, my gosh.
你必须卸下防备，狠狠地痛斥某人一番。对于伯纳德家族来说，传统上这发生在感恩节。所以这将是一个很好的预演。你能想象安迪·伯纳德父母家的感恩节是什么样的吗？我无法想象。他们会向他发起多少次言语攻击？哦，天哪。
All right, here's one from Kevin.
Kevin would have said,
Michael letting us tell him how much he sucks is probably the coolest thing he's ever done.
He set up a PA system and everything.
And lastly, here is one from Oscar that really paints a picture.
I mean, Michael has no idea what he's in for.
Oscar would have said, as an accountant, it's my duty to measure the value of roasting Michael
against the potential of getting fired,
好的，凯文这里有一段。凯文本来会说，迈克让大家评头论足他有多烂，这可能是他做过最酷的事了。他甚至还架设了扩音设备。最后，奥斯卡这段话非常生动传神。我的意思是，迈克根本不知道自己将面对什么。奥斯卡本来会说，作为一名会计，我的职责是权衡取笑迈克的价值与被解雇的风险，
but as a man, I have no choice but to destroy him.
Destroy him.
Destroy.
Oh, and if you think the roasts that made it into the actual episode were rough on Michael,
just wait until you hear the alts, OMG.
But, guys, it's time for the roast.
Michael is so excited to get it started.
但作为一个男人，我别无选择，只能摧毁他。摧毁他。摧毁他。摧毁。哦，如果你觉得正片里那些对迈克的吐槽已经够狠了，那等你们听到备选台词再说吧，我的天呐。不过，伙计们，吐槽大会开始了。迈克兴奋极了，迫不及待地要开始了。
This is going to take a turn very quickly,
but let's hear his opening speech just full of enthusiasm.
Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome.
You are all jerks.
Just kidding.
Not yet anyway.
Welcome to the roast of Mr. Michael Scott.
If you're here for the Grabowski wedding,
这气氛很快就会急转直下，但我们先来听听他充满热情的开场白。欢迎，欢迎，欢迎，欢迎，欢迎。你们全都是混蛋。开玩笑的。反正现在还不是。欢迎来到迈克·斯科特先生的吐槽大会。如果你是来参加格拉鲍斯基的婚礼的，
it is the second door on the left.
So we all know how these work.
Needs to get crazy.
Take your best shot.
I am going to sit right over a chair.
And whoever wants to come up and roast me, you may.
Okay.
Well, Angela, you are first up.
那是左边数第二扇门。所以大家都知道这些是怎么运作的。得玩嗨一点。尽管放马过来。我就坐在这张椅子上。谁想上来吐槽我都可以。好吧。安吉拉，你第一个上。
Oh, yeah.
I charged the stage.
Yes.
And dare I say, I think it's the best roast.
No.
I really do.
I really, really do.
And I didn't see it coming, you know?
哦，对。我冲上了舞台。是的。而且我敢说，我觉得这是最棒的吐槽。不是。我真的是这么觉得。真的，真的是这样。而且我事先完全没想到，你知道吗？
Like, I think as a fan of the show, you don't necessarily think that Angela is going
to be a really good roaster.
But she is.
She's going to roast him like a la Jeff Foxworthy style.
That's how it's described in the script.
It says Angela does a very bland Jeff Foxworthy.
And something I feel like we should share with people
is that the super fan episode does not have a bunch of extra roast stuff in it.
就像，我觉得作为这部剧的粉丝，你不会觉得安吉拉会是一个很厉害的吐槽手。但她确实是。她要用杰夫·福克斯沃西的风格来吐槽他。剧本里就是这么描述的。剧本说安吉拉模仿了一种非常平淡的杰夫·福克斯沃西风格。我觉得我们有一件事应该告诉大家，那就是超级粉丝版剧集中并没有包含一堆额外的吐槽内容。
That's right.
Even though we filmed a bunch,
there's only two characters.
We'll get to them where they're extended.
Yes.
So this is Angela's Roast of Michael.
If you ever wondered whether you were Michael Scott,
here's a quiz to help.
没错。尽管我们拍了很多，但只有两个角色的内容得到了扩展，我们待会儿会讲到。是的。所以这是安吉拉对迈克的吐槽。如果你曾怀疑过自己是不是迈克·斯科特，这里有个测试能帮你确认。
If you ever put sunblock on a window,
you might be Michael Scott.
If you ever called the fire department
because your head was stuck in your chair,
you might be...
Michael Scott.
I thought those were very good,
and they were also, like,
如果你曾在窗户上涂防晒霜，你可能就是迈克·斯科特。如果你曾因为头卡在椅子里而拨打消防电话，你可能就是……迈克·斯科特。我觉得这些非常棒，而且它们也，
they weren't too mean, but they were true.
And, you know, I remember some of the direction
the director Jeff Blitz gave me was,
after the first one goes well,
the second one, he was like,
why don't you just like take the mic off the stand
and start strutting around?
You know, like you're really,
它们不是特别刻薄，但却很真实。而且，我记得导演杰夫·布里茨给我的指导之一是，在第一个包袱效果不错之后，第二个包袱时，他说，你为什么不干脆把麦克风从支架上拿下来，开始昂首阔步地走呢？你知道的，就像你真的，
She's really filling herself.
Yeah.
Well, Angela had a few more Jeff Foxworthy-style jokes in the alts.
Angela, will you read them?
They make my day.
Sure.
If you've ever frozen your hand to your car because you were washing it in the winter,
then you might be Michael Scott.
她真的很自我感觉良好。是啊。好吧，安吉拉在备选台词里还有几个杰夫·福克斯沃西风格的笑话。安吉拉，你能读一下吗？它们让我一整天都有好心情。当然。如果你曾在冬天洗车时把手冻在车上，那么你可能就是迈克·斯科特。
If you've ever conned a publicly traded corporation into letting you run a branch,
you might be Michael Scott.
If you think the military draft and the football draft are the same.
thing you might be Michael Scott so good well next up is Kelly and here's what made it into the
superfan episode I have made a list of people that I would make out with before I would make out
with Michael Scott a turtle a fridge anybody from the warehouse a wood chipper Kevin a candle
and Lord Voldemort anyway happy birthday Michael yeah you'd be so lucky
So are you ready for some crazy alts?
如果你曾哄骗一家上市公司让你运营一家分公司，你可能就是迈克·斯科特。如果你认为军队征兵和橄榄球选秀是一回事，你可能就是迈克·斯科特。太棒了。好了，接下来上场的是凯利，这是进入超级粉丝版的片段：我列了一份名单，上面的人我都愿意跟他亲热，也不愿意和迈克·斯科特亲热：一只乌龟、一台冰箱、仓库里的任何一个人、一台碎木机、凯文、一支蜡烛以及伏地魔。不管怎样，迈克，生日快乐。是啊，你可真幸运。那么，你们准备好听一些疯狂的备选台词了吗？
Okay.
First of all, in the candy bag, not only does Kelly roast Michael, but then she turns on her
co-workers and singles a few people out.
Let's start with the alts for her Michael roast.
Kelly would have said, they say a good boss sweats the details.
Michael is just really sweaty.
Seriously, you guys, it's gross.
And another one?
好的。首先，在糖果袋的备选里，凯利不仅吐槽了迈克，接着她还把矛头指向了同事，点名批评了好几个人。让我们从她对迈克的备选吐槽开始。凯利原本会说，他们说好老板会关注细节。迈克只是真的很会出汗。说真的，你们大家，这太恶心了。还有另一个？
We've made a lot of fun of Michael tonight, but I'd actually like to bring up.
propose a toast, and she holds up her glass.
Few people in this world are as smart or as funny or as good-hearted as Michael Scott thinks he is.
So let's all toast this dumb, corny prick.
Oh my God.
But are you ready for what she said about Pam?
Okay, I remember these because I think we shot some of these.
They are not in the super fan episode, but I remember them because Kelly loves to take on Pam.
今晚我们拿迈克开了很多玩笑，但实际上我想提议，提议敬个酒，然后她举起了杯子。这世上极少有人能像迈克·斯科特自以为的那样聪明、有趣或心地善良。所以让我们一起为这个愚蠢、老套的混蛋干杯。哦我的天呐。不过，你们准备好听她是怎么评价帕姆的吗？好吧，我还记得这些，因为我觉得我们拍过其中的一些。它们没有出现在超级粉丝版里，但我记得是因为凯利很喜欢针对帕姆。
Mm-hmm.
Here we go.
Kelly would have said about Pam. Pam, if it weren't for you, I'd definitely be the prettiest girl in this office hands down. And I really wish I didn't always get that competitive vibe from you. The truth is, if I won a gym, I could have had him. So get over it. And then she turns to the crowd and goes, you guys can laugh anytime you want. That's what I mean. I feel like I remember that. Well, everyone, now get ready because it's Meredith's turn. Let's hear what.
made it into the episode.
Michael?
You ran over me with your car.
You posted a picture
of my bare boobs on the bulletin board
嗯哼。我们开始吧。凯利原本会说帕姆：帕姆，要不是因为你，我绝对是这办公室里最好看的女孩，毫无疑问。而且我真的很希望我没有总是从你身上感受到那种好胜的氛围。事实是，如果我拿下吉姆，我本来也可以拥有他。所以看开点吧。然后她转向观众说，你们随时都可以笑。这就是我的意思。我觉得我好像还记得那场戏。好了，各位，现在请准备，因为轮到梅雷迪思了。我们来听听什么内容最终剪进了正片。迈克？你用车把我撞了。你在公告栏上贴了一张我光着胸部的照片，
with a caption that said,
gross.
Well.
Michael, you are the reason I drink.
You are the reason I live to forget.
That's one of the ones where he does his finger.
His finger guns.
Yes, he also does the drum.
配的说明是：恶心。好吧。迈克，你就是我酗酒的原因。你是我活下去为了忘记的原因。这是他做出那个手势的片段之一。他的手指枪。是的，他在那段里还打了架子鼓。
in that one.
All right, well, here is Meredith's crazy alt.
Buckle in, it gets dark, folks.
Meredith says, you're the reason I live to forget.
You're the reason I go to a gun range to blow off steam.
You, Michael Scott, are the reason why I capture small rodents and torture them.
Those poor rodents, what did they do?
Oh, my gosh.
在那个片段里。好吧，梅雷迪思疯狂的备选台词来喽。系好安全带，这部分有点暗黑，各位。梅雷迪思说，你是我活下去为了忘记的原因。你是我去射击场宣泄怒火的原因。你，迈克·斯科特，就是我捕捉小型啮齿动物并虐待它们的原因。那些可怜的小动物，它们做错了什么？哦，天哪。
I mean, what?
What?
That's dark.
It's very dark.
Very, very intense.
But wait, and I remember this from the day.
Meredith also had roasts for her other co-workers, including Jim and Pam.
我的意思是，什么？什么？什么？这太黑暗了。非常黑暗。非常非常强烈。但是等等，我从当天的拍摄中还记得。梅雷迪思对其他同事也有吐槽，包括吉姆和帕姆。
I remember this, that there was this like sort of alt storyline where for whatever reason people pile on Jim and Pam during this rose.
So Meredith would have said, Pam and Jim think they are so cute.
Guess what?
You didn't invent humping.
Get over yourself.
That's funny.
Okay, next up is Oscar, and his roast is extended.
Okay, it's one of the ones that got extra footage in the superfan version.
我记得这一点，当时有这样一种备选剧情线：不管出于什么原因，大家在这场吐槽大会上把矛头都指向了吉姆和帕姆。所以梅雷迪思原本会说，帕姆和吉姆觉得自己太可爱了。你猜怎么着？你们可没发明“酱酱酿酿”。别自我感觉良好了。这太搞笑了。好的，接下来是奥斯卡，他的吐槽被加长了。好吧，这是超级粉丝版中获得额外画面的片段之一。
I want you to hear it.
The only man in the state of Pennsylvania who is less likely to get legally married than me is Michael Scott.
Michael is so bad with money.
He invested in Enron.
Last week.
That was privileged.
He thinks balancing a checkbook is putting a checkbook on his nose.
and shouting, look at me, look at me!
我想让你们听听。宾夕法尼亚州合法结婚概率比我还低的男人，只有迈克·斯科特。迈克对金钱一窍不通。他投资了安然。就在上周。那是机密。他以为平衡支票簿就是把支票簿放在鼻子上，
Me da'ne out of every day that I despiato and I have to come to work, for you.
For you.
Okay, so he really goes at him.
But there was so much more in the candy bag alts.
Oscar actually might have had the most alts next to Pam.
Lady, there's so many.
I think we each share a few.
Okay.
然后大喊，看我，看我！我每天醒来（西语），我都必须来上班，为了你。为了你。好吧，所以他是真的在针对他。但糖果袋的备选台词里还有更多料。在帕姆之后，奥斯卡实际上的备选台词可能是最多的。天哪，有太多了。我觉得我们每个人分享几个。好的。
All right, I'll go first.
Oscar would have said, Michael loves jokes.
Here's a joke for you.
Michael is smart.
Oscar would have said, I'd say Michael was as dumb as a rock, but rocks are able to go a whole day without telling a dumb joke.
Rocks don't make you sit through meetings about how we're having too many meetings.
Rocks don't have parties to celebrate National Pharmacist's Day.
And here's two more.
好吧，我先来。奥斯卡原本会说，迈克喜欢笑话。这里有个笑话讲给你听。迈克很聪明。奥斯卡原本会说，我会说迈克笨得像块石头，但石头至少能一整天不讲冷笑话。石头不会让你坐下来开会讨论我们开会怎么开得太多。石头不会举办派对来庆祝“全国药剂师日”。这里还有两个。
Oscar would have said, Michael, what's the difference between you and a car alarm?
At least a car alarm has a purpose.
Oh.
Or remember when I briefly convinced you that math,
was spelled M-A-F-F, worst day of my life.
Was he walking around saying math?
Probably.
And Oscar, like Kelly and Meredith, also turns on his co-workers in the room.
奥斯卡原本会说，迈克，你和一个汽车警报器有什么区别？至少汽车警报器还有点用处。哦。或者还记得我曾短暂地说服你，数学（math）的拼写是 M-A-F-F 那天是我一生中最糟糕的一天。他当时在到处说数学是m-a-f-f吗？很可能。而且奥斯卡，就像凯利和梅雷迪思一样，也把矛头转向了房间里的其他同事。
Oscar would have said this.
You hear a lot of phrases these days.
Layoffs, price at the pump, sinkhole, but enough about Meredith.
Mm-hmm.
And then he turns on Angela.
Listen to this one.
He said, what do Dwight and Andy and Alon have in common?
Angela has hosed all of them.
奥斯卡原本会说这些。你现在经常能听到很多词汇。裁员、油价、天坑，不过说够梅雷迪思了。嗯哼。然后他转向了安吉拉。听听这个。他说，德怀特、安迪和阿隆有什么共同点？安吉拉把他们全都甩了。
What the hell, Oscar?
Geez.
Well, now Toby tries to come up to roast Michael, but Michael screams at him.
He says, no, friends only, friends only.
So we never get to hear what Toby might have said, but guess what?
They did write some jokes in the candy bag alts for Toby.
And the thing that is so amazing to me about that is that I know they never had any intention
of letting Toby get up on stage to Rose Michael.
搞什么鬼，奥斯卡？天哪。好吧，现在托比试图上台吐槽迈克，但迈克冲他尖叫。他说，不，只限朋友，只限朋友。所以我们永远不知道托比会说些什么，但你猜怎么着？他们确实为托比在糖果袋备选里写了一些笑话。最让我感到惊奇的是，我知道他们压根就没打算让托比上台去吐槽迈克。
No.
Never.
But the writers could not stop themselves
from writing Roses from Toby's perspective anyway.
Oh, yeah.
They actually wrote Alt Rose for every character on the show.
We are actually just going by the ones
that actually had moments coming up to stage,
没有。从来没有。但编剧们还是情不自禁地从托比的角度写了吐槽词。哦，是的。他们实际上为剧中的每个角色都写了备选吐槽。我们其实只是按那些真正有上台瞬间的角色来盘点，
but there was so much stuff for, like, everybody.
There was like this whole weird list of alt jokes
where Phyllis gets on stage and roast Stanley.
Yes, she singles out Stanley.
For like an entire page.
I know.
Craziness.
Okay, so here is what Toby might have said
但关于其他所有人，真的有太多素材了。甚至还有一个很奇怪的备选笑话列表，讲的是菲莉丝上台吐槽斯坦利。是的，她单单挑出了斯坦利。整整写了一页纸。我知道。太疯狂了。好吧，所以如果托比有机会吐槽迈克，
if he had a chance to roast Michael.
They say the ice caps are melting
and that polar bears are endangered,
also endangered all of us from radon poisoning
because Michael doesn't believe it's a serious threat.
This radon runner is one of my absolute favorite things
of the entire show.
Same.
他原本会说这些。他们说冰川在融化，北极熊濒临灭绝，而由于迈克不相信氡气中毒是个严重的威胁，我们所有人也都因氡气中毒而濒临灭绝。这个氡气梗绝对是我整部剧中最喜欢的桥段之一。我也是。
I love his obsession with the radon poisoning.
Toby also had this alt.
It's important to remember that Michael was not always the incompetent manager he is today.
He used to be an incompetent salesman.
Now it's Jim's turn, and I want to read you how it's set up in the shooting draft.
It says, Jim comes up and puts a large diagram on an easel.
It shows an outline of a man's body with arrows pointing to various body parts.
his roast and the superfan is much longer than what originally aired.
我太喜欢他对氡气中毒的执念了。托比还有这样一个备选。重要的是要记住，迈克并不总是他今天这个无能的经理。他曾经是个无能的销售员。现在轮到吉姆了，我想读给你们听听拍摄剧本里是怎么设定的。上面写着，吉姆上台，在画架上放了一张大型图表。图上是一个男人的身体轮廓，箭头指向各个身体部位。他在超级粉丝版里的吐槽比最初播出的要长得多。
I want you guys to hear it.
These are actually injuries that Michael has had, starting off with repeated burnt tongue
from over-eager Pop-Tart consumption,
a torn ACL from trying to hurdle Angela one day,
bruised testy, same scenario,
you burned your foot on a foreman grill.
These are just a few things that have been caught in Michael's zipper.
His finger, a sandwich.
我想让你们听听。这些其实都是迈克受过的伤，从因为急着吃波点挞而频繁烫伤舌头开始，为了有朝一日能飞越安吉拉而撕裂的前十字韧带，睾丸淤青——同一场景，你在乔治 Foreman 电烤架上烫伤了脚。这些只是被迈克拉链夹住过的一小部分东西。他的手指，三明治。
Kevin's finger, trying to remove that sandwich.
Big question mark.
That would stand for a list of contents that are in Michael's stomach that we know of.
A pound of chewing gum.
Two peach pits.
At least five keys from the Houdini Magic Handcuff set.
Oh, his new favorite are these new edible M&M wrappers.
but they're not edible because it was an internet hoax.
凯文的手指，试图把那个三明治弄出来。巨大的问号。这代表我们所知的迈克胃里的内容物清单。一磅口香糖。两颗桃核。至少五把来自胡迪尼魔术手铐套装的钥匙。哦，他现在最喜欢的是这些新出的可食用 M&M 巧克力豆包装纸。但它们根本不能吃，因为那是个网络恶作剧。
What else?
Well, several times a day, Michael says words that are way beyond my vocabulary.
I know where this is going.
Do you?
No.
Okay.
Remember spider face?
No.
还有什么？嗯，迈克一天到晚都会说一些远远超出我词汇量的词。我知道这要扯到哪去了。你知道吗？不知道。好吧。还记得蜘蛛脸吗？不。
Okay, because the quote was, cut off your nose to spider face.
Spiter, okay.
Yep.
So the alts for Jim were just more and more speeches like that, just more and more things.
and it was so long, but we thought just playing the extended clip would give you an idea.
Well, next up, Dwight gets very upset.
He goes up on stage.
He's going to defend Michael.
好吧，因为当时的台词是，割掉鼻子去蜘蛛脸。斯派特（Spiter），好吧。没错。所以吉姆的备选台词就是越来越多的这种演讲，越来越多的东西，而且太长了，但我们觉得只播一下加长片段就能让你们有个概念。好吧，接下来，德怀特非常生气。他上了台。他要为迈克辩护。
Yeah.
But Michael and him end up getting into a fight, and then Dwight inadvertently ross him by calling him a pathetic short little man that doesn't have any friends or family or any land.
And guess what?
There were no alts for that.
None.
No.
I think this was a very important plot.
point that you see Dwight, like, turn on Michael?
是啊。但最终他和迈克吵了起来，然后德怀特无意中吐槽了他，骂他是一个既没有朋友、没有家人、也没有土地的悲哀的小矮个子男人。你猜怎么着？那段没有任何备选台词。完全没有。没有。我觉得这是一个非常重要的剧情转折点，你看到德怀特竟然背叛了迈克？
Mm-hmm.
Because it's really, like, now Michael is, like, kind of without a defender or any friends, like, truly in this ring.
Yeah.
He's solo. Yeah. He's totally alone up there. And then it's Pam's turn. Oh, my goodness, lady.
Pam is going to tie with Oscar for Best Snarky Ross in the Candy Bag Alts.
First, let's hear, but made it into the actual episode.
Well, I just want to take a minute to talk to you all about something very serious.
Once every hour, someone is involved in an internet scam.
嗯哼。因为这真的就像是，现在迈克可以说是没有了辩护人，也没有了任何朋友，在这个擂台里孤立无援。对。他是单打独斗。是的。他在上面孤零零的。然后轮到帕姆了。哦，天哪，天哪。在糖果袋备选里，帕姆的尖酸刻薄吐槽将与奥斯卡并列第一。首先，我们先听听最终剪进正片的内容。好吧，我想花点时间跟你们谈谈一件非常严肃的事。每隔一小时，就会有人卷入网络骗局。
That man is Michael Scott.
He's supporting about 20 Nigerian princesses.
Hey, you know what?
Forgive me for caring, right?
Well, you know, Michael is a great delegator.
He never does any work himself, ever.
Ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha.
那个男人就是迈克·斯科特。他资助了大约 20 位尼日利亚公主。嘿，你知道吗？原谅我有爱心，行吗？好吧，你知道的，迈克是个绝佳的甩手掌柜。他自己从来不做任何工作，从来不。哈哈！哈哈哈哈。
And one time I walked in on him naked,
and his thing is so small.
How small is it?
If it were an iPod, it would be a shuffle.
Oh, I know.
She went there.
Can I say one thing?
而且有一次我撞见他光着身子，他的那个东西太小了。有多小？如果它是个 iPod，那它就是 shuffle。哦，我懂。她真敢说。她真的豁出去了。我能说一件事吗？
What?
Since I am Michael's mingled phrases of this duo,
you are Michael's internet scam person.
You have, over the course of our friendship,
fallen for several internet scams.
Sam knows it as well.
Including our anagram test that I made everybody take.
Where we paid $1.95 and then we found out that we were secretly charged.
什么？既然我是迈克错乱词汇的最佳搭档，你就是迈克式的网络受骗者。在我们的友谊历程中，你曾多次陷入网络骗局。萨姆也很清楚这一点。包括我让大家都做的那个字谜测试。我们付了 1.95 美元，然后发现我们被暗中扣费了。
We were secretly entered into a subscription for $45 a month.
I'm so sorry.
It did seem too good to be true.
It was truly perfect.
It took a full day before it debited out of my account.
Anyway, okay.
You're right.
Right. So we are the perfect duo, lady.
我们被暗中订购了一个每月 45 美元的套餐。实在是对不起。这看起来确实好得令人难以置信。简直完美。过了一整天才从我的账户里扣款。不管怎样，好吧。你说得对。对。所以我们俩是绝配，天哪。
You know what I also did? My daughter came to me, what was it? She wanted a jelly cat.
Oh, you were so excited. I saw this whole journey. Because first you were like,
Ange, these jelly cats are on sale. But only for the next hour.
Like, I had to quickly, like, log on, and I'm so excited because we got these jelly cats.
Yes. And so, like, I went on and I, like, I entered my credit card information. And then it said something, and it needed a different credit card.
I'm like, ah! So I'm like, I'm in a rush. I entered three credit cards.
You guys, basically, you gave out. It got all my credit cards.
And you had to cancel all my credit cards. And the way we found out was the next morning, my daughter was like, Mom, the sale is still going on.
你知道我还干了什么吗？我女儿来找我，是什么来着？她想要一只果冻猫（Jellycat）。哦，你当时太兴奋了。我见证了你这一整个心路历程。因为一开始你是说，安吉，这些果冻猫在打折。但只持续一个小时。就像，我必须赶快登录，我太兴奋了，因为我们抢到了这些果冻猫。是的。所以，就像，我上去了，然后，就像，我输入了我的信用卡信息。然后它提示了什么，需要一张不同的信用卡。我说，啊！所以我想，我很着急。我输入了三张信用卡。伙计们，基本上，你把……它拿到了我所有的信用卡。你不得不把我所有的信用卡都挂失了。我们发现这件事的方式是第二天早上，我女儿说，妈妈，促销还在继续呢。
And you're like, but I thought it was only an hour.
I'm like, when I went on the website, there was like a countdown clock. And I was like, wait.
And I went back and it was the same countdown clock.
Yeah.
Lady, it gets worse.
You think it can't get worse.
I texted that link to the mom chat.
而你说，但我以为只有一个小时呢。我说，当我打开网站时，上面有一个倒计时钟。然后我说，等等。然后我回去看，还是同一个倒计时钟。是啊。天哪，情况更糟了。是啊。你以为不可能更糟了。我把那个链接发到了妈妈聊天群里。
I was like, guys, jelly cats are sale for an hour.
So you got me and Sam and Matt in an internet scam and the mom text thread.
And the mom text thread.
And so that morning I was like, oh my God, I hope no one ordered any jelly cats.
Guess what?
It's a scam.
They're not actually selling jelly cats for $15.
They're just fishing for your credit card information.
我说，伙计们，果冻猫打折一小时。所以你把我和萨姆还有马特都坑进了一个网络骗局里，还发到了妈妈微信群里。发到了妈妈微信群里。所以那天早上我就想，天哪，希望没人订购果冻猫。你猜怎么着？是个骗局。他们根本没有以 15 美元的价格卖果冻猫。他们只是在钓鱼获取你的信用卡信息。
And they were like, it's okay.
We didn't order any.
But thanks for like, no.
Oh, my God.
Now you know why we had to dance so hard last night.
We've been through a lot.
You've been through a lot together.
Anyway, I'm just saying we both are sides of Michael.
然后他们说，没关系。我们没订购。不过谢谢你的……不。哦，天哪。现在你知道为什么我们昨晚必须那么卖力地跳舞了。我们经历了很多。你们一起经历了很多。不管怎样，我只是说我们两个展现了迈克的两面。
This is true.
This is very true.
But back to Pam, you have to share some of Pam's roast alts for Michael, Jenna.
She does have some good roast alts.
Okay.
here they are. Michael is so dumb that Kevin thinks he's dumb. Michael Scott is to comedy as Angela is to
comedy. Hey. I know. All right. How about this one? No one in the office spends more time with Michael
than I do. Anyone up for tradeses? Michael doesn't wash his hands after he pees. On many occasions,
这是真的。这绝对是真的。但回到帕姆，珍娜，你得分享一些帕姆对迈克的备选吐槽。她确实有一些精彩的备选吐槽。好吧，它们在这里。迈克太笨了，连凯文都觉得他笨。迈克·斯科特之于喜剧，正如安吉拉之于喜剧。嘿。我知道。好吧。这个怎么样？办公室里陪迈克时间最长的人就是我。有人想换换吗？迈克上完厕所不洗手。有很多次，
I've watched him go right from the bathroom into his office to eat a sandwich. Michael is a
piss eater, everyone.
Someone else doesn't wash their hands sometimes.
Hey, I don't touch my business when I pee.
And then you don't eat after you pee.
Thank you.
And then this one, what's the difference between a hockey mom and Michael Scott?
A hockey mom has children.
我都看着他直接从卫生间走进办公室去吃三明治。迈克是个吃尿狂魔，各位。还有别人有时候也不洗手。嘿，我上完厕所不碰我的命根子。然后你上完厕所就不会吃东西。谢谢。还有这个，曲棍球妈妈和迈克·斯科特有什么区别？曲棍球妈妈有孩子。
Too mean, too far.
How about this one?
Scientists say that a man who stares at boobs for 10 minutes a day can add many years to his life.
So by my count, Michael will live to about 307.
What did he call him Pam and her Pam?
Pam. Pam and her Pam. So many. So many. So many things.
All right, you guys. But then Pam is going to roast the room. And she goes scorched earth on her coworkers.
Yeah. Listen to these alts. Pam would have said, I'm not sure any of you know this, but Andy Bernard went to Cornell, where he majored in never shutting up about Cornell.
太刻薄了，太过分了。这个怎么样？科学家说，一个男人每天盯着胸部看 10 分钟，可以为他的寿命增加很多年。所以按我的计算，迈克能活到 307 岁左右。他管帕姆叫什么来着？帕姆和她的帕姆。帕姆。帕姆和她的帕姆。有太多的梗了。太多了。太多东西了。好吧，各位。但接着帕姆要吐槽整个房间了。她对同事们进行了毁灭性的打击。是啊。听听这些备选台词。帕姆原本会说，我不确定你们当中有谁知道这一点，但安吉拉毕业于康奈尔大学，她在那里主修“喋喋不休地谈论康奈尔大学”。
If Cornell is so freaking good, what the hell are you doing in Dunder Mifflin?
Most of us got here without any community college.
Hey, Andy, can you sing tenor?
Ten or twelve miles away from here?
Wow.
And then she would have turned on Toby.
Pam would have said, Toby, Scarborough Fair is depressing enough,
but having to hear you hum it over and over every day is about as fun as your Costa Rica pictures.
如果康奈尔大学那么牛逼，你到底在邓德米弗林干什么？我们大多数人来这儿之前都没上过社区大学。嘿，安迪，你能唱男高音（tenor）吗？离这儿十（ten）或十二英里远的地方？哇。然后她把矛头转向了托比。帕姆原本会说，托比，《斯卡布罗集市》已经够让人沮丧的了，但还得每天听你哼哼唧唧，简直和看你在哥斯达黎加的照片一样有趣。
Oh, Toby would not have recovered.
No.
And then Pam just really.
opens up. She would have said, hey, Michael, what's with the world's best boss mug? You don't see Meredith
with a mug that says virgin. You don't see Jim with humble. Or Kelly with fascinating. Or Kevin with
genius. Or Creed with normal. Or the entire office with a mug that says, this place doesn't suck.
Okay. That one actually really made me laugh. I just have to point out, does Pam actually think Jim is a little smudge?
Yeah. I think so. All right. Well, next up is Daryl. And rather than roasting Michael, he asked him if he can name one of the warehouse workers who is sitting in the back of the room. And Michael cannot. Even though said warehouse guy gave him a ride home the week before and they spent an hour in traffic.
哦，托比绝对缓不过劲来。没有。然后帕姆彻底敞开了。她原本会说，嘿，迈克，你那个“世界最佳老板”的杯子是怎么回事？你不会看到梅雷迪思拿着用“处女”标示的杯子。你不会看到吉姆拿着标有“谦逊”的杯子。或者凯利拿着“迷人”的杯子。或者凯文拿着“天才”的杯子。或者克里德拿着“正常”的杯子。或者整个办公室拿着一个写着“这地方不烂”的杯子。好吧。那句真的让我笑出声来。我不得不指出，帕姆真的觉得吉姆有点蠢萌吗？对。我想是的。好吧，接下来是达里尔。与其吐槽迈克，他反问迈克能不能叫出一个坐在房间后面的仓库工人的名字。而迈克叫不出来。尽管这个所谓的仓库小哥前一周才载过他回家，他们还在交通拥堵中待了一个小时。
Yeah. And as it turns out, the guy's name was Michael. Yes. Super cringy. But Daryl did have a few roast alts. Here are
too. Daryl would have said, here's a list of all the song parodies Michael has asked me to work on
with him. Pour some sugar on meat. Born in East L.A., I had to tell him that already existed.
I want to hold your boobs. My fart will go on, the fart of rock and roll, boner of a lonely fart.
Every time you go away, you take a piece of pee with poo. Wow. Yeah. Michael really loves a song
where he can work in the word fart.
He really does.
Here's another one.
是啊。结果证明，那家伙的名字叫迈克。是的。超级尴尬。但达里尔确实有一些备选吐槽。这里有两个。达里尔原本会说，这是迈克让我跟他一起创作的所有恶搞歌曲列表。把一些糖倒在肉上（Pour some sugar on meat）。生于东洛杉矶（Born in East L.A.）——我不得不告诉他那首歌早就存在了。我想握住你的胸部（I want to hold your boobs）。我的屁将继续，摇滚乐之屁，孤独屁的硬汉。每次你离开，你都带走了带屎的一小块尿。哇。是啊。迈克真的很喜欢那种能把“屁”字塞进去的歌。他确实很喜欢。这里还有另一个。
Daryl would have said,
Michael's in pretty good shape,
but I guess it's easy to get to the gym
when you don't have any friends, family,
or people who don't want to choke your ass out.
Michael's the only person on Micepace that Tom won't be friends with.
Wow, a Micepace joke.
I mean, people really are going at him for being like no friend, no kids.
达里尔原本会说，迈克身材保持得挺好，但我想，当你没有朋友、没有家人、也没有人想把你掐死时，去健身房是挺容易的。迈克是 MySpace 上唯一一个汤姆（Tom）都不愿意加为好友的人。哇，一个 MySpace 的梗。我的意思是，大家真的在疯狂攻击他没有朋友、没有孩子这一点。
I know.
It's rough.
It's really rough.
Well, after Daryl,
Oscar comes back up onto stage and he has Jan on speakerphone and she just roast the heck out of Michael.
We played that clip in our original breakdown, but basically she says you ruined my life.
Everything you touch turns to crap. You have no sense of how to please any woman.
I can't believe you wrote a phone message on my diploma and you use my daughter's christening gown as a bib when you ate ribs.
我知道。太残酷了。真的非常残酷。好吧，在达里尔之后，奥斯卡重新回到舞台上，他把简的电话开了免提，简把迈克狠狠地吐槽了一通。我们在原本的拆解中播放过那个片段，但基本上她说的是，你毁了我的生活。你碰过的一切都变成了狗屎。你根本不知道怎么取悦任何女人。我简直不敢相信你在我的毕业证书上写了留言，而且你吃排骨时竟然用我女儿的洗礼长袍当围嘴。
You are just completely an ass, Michael.
And then I shared one of my favorite candy bag alts for this when we first broke this down.
but there were so many more, I have to read you two of Jan's alts.
One, Michael stole my soul and used it as toilet paper.
So dramatic.
I know.
This is why, like, Jan, the drama.
Also, if mankind was truly created in God's image, Michael is proof that our creator had genital warp.
你简直就是个混蛋，迈克尔。当时我们刚拆解这一集时，我还分享了我最喜欢的糖果袋备选台词之一，但还有太多了，我必须把简的两条备选台词读给你们听。第一条：“迈克尔偷走了我的灵魂，并把它当成卫生纸。”太戏剧化了。我知道。这就是为什么，你看，简，太戏剧化了。另外，如果人类真的是按上帝的形象创造的，那迈克尔就是我们造物主生殖器畸形的证据。
Oh, my gosh.
So rough.
Okay.
Well, the roast of Michael Scott ends with Andy.
You know, he's going to get up and sing a song parody.
Yes, let's hear it.
Andy suck is a ball.
The looseriest, jerky is and you're dumber than apple sauce.
哦，天哪。太粗鲁了。好吧。对迈克尔·斯科特的吐槽大会以安迪收尾。你知道的，他要起身上台唱一首歌曲恶搞。是的，让我们听听。安迪吸了一个球。最窝囊的混蛋，你比苹果酱还要蠢。
We're stuck listening to you all day.
Stanley tried to die just to get away when it's true.
That's what I hate about.
I mean, I know we're here to talk about the roast, but every time Andy has to end a song with a he,
D, B, D, D, D, it gets me every time.
Oh, okay.
The candy bag alts were mostly more lyrics for this song, okay?
我们一整天都被迫听你唠叨。斯坦利为了逃避甚至差点去死，如果这是真的。这就是我讨厌的地方。这就是我讨厌的地方。我是说，我知道我们今天是来聊吐槽大会的，但每次安迪唱完歌都要加上一句“嘿、D、B、D、D、D”，每次都戳中我。哦，好吧。糖果袋备选台词大部分都是这首歌的更多歌词，好吧？
But there was one roast alt that was so on brand for Andy.
I just want to share it.
You know Andy's love of nicknames?
Yes.
Okay.
Andy would have said,
Michael, I've been trying to find a nickname for you,
but there are so many good ones.
但有一个吐槽备选台词非常符合安迪的风格。我只想分享一下。你知道安迪对绰号的热爱吧？是的。好吧，安迪本会说：“迈克尔，我一直在试图为你找一个绰号，但好绰号实在是太多了。”
I thought I'd give you the top ten.
Boss lady.
Ten dollar suit.
The incompinator.
Hair club for men.
Pubes.
Toilet monster.
bad breath, Jeff, that might have been on a garbage pale kid, Mr. Lonely Pants, Michael Snott,
我想我应该给你列出前十名。老板娘。十美元西装。精算终结者。美发男士俱乐部。阴毛。厕所怪物。口臭杰夫，那可能是在垃圾桶小子卡片上看到的，孤独裤子先生，迈克尔·鼻涕，
and Drumroll, Childless Failure.
Oh, my gosh. I feel like Boss Lady and $10 suit are just references to that same episode
where Michael bought the lady's suit. And when I first read this, I thought it was Hair Club
for Men Pubes, like one thing. Yeah, and then I was like, oh, there's a comma.
So after the roast ends, Michael does not take things well.
I mean, it was rough on him.
He had planned to stand up and kind of roast everybody back.
Yeah.
还有鼓点，无子女的失败者。哦，天哪。我觉得“老板娘”和“10美元西装”只是在致敬迈克尔买那套女士西装的那集。当我第一次读到这个时，我还以为是“美发男士俱乐部阴毛”，就像是一回事。是的，然后我想，哦，这里有个逗号。所以吐槽大会结束后，迈克尔的情绪非常糟糕。我的他是说，这对他的打击很大。他原本打算站起来回怼每一个人。是的。
But he can't get through it.
He walks off the stage.
He like does that, oh, that super awkward heartbreaking moment where he like runs into the drum and has to set it back up again.
So he actually takes a personal day.
He puts on his turtleneck.
He reflects at the park.
He ultimately comes back into the office and decides.
that he is going to roast everyone.
但他根本说不下去。他走下了舞台。他做那个，哦，那个超级尴尬、令人心碎的动作，不小心撞到了架子鼓，不得不把它重新扶起来。所以他实际上请了一天个人假。他穿上高领毛衣。在公园里反思。最终他回到办公室，决定，
Yeah.
Let's hear it.
Jim, you're 6-11,
and you weigh 90 pounds.
Gumbie has a better body than you.
Boom, roasted.
Dwight, you're a kiss-ass.
他要吐槽在场的每一个人。是的。让我们听听。吉姆，你身高六尺十一寸，体重九十磅。甘比的身材都比你好。轰，被吐槽了。德怀特，你是个马屁精。轰，被吐槽了。
Pam, you failed art school?
Boom, roasted.
Meredith.
You've slept with so many guys,
you're starting to look like one.
Boom, roasted.
Kevin, I can't decide between a fat joke
and a dumb joke, boom, roasted.
帕姆，你艺术学校没毕业？轰，被吐槽了。梅雷迪思。你跟那么多男人睡过，现在看起来就像个男人了。轰，被吐槽了。凯文，我在胖子笑话和蠢人笑话之间做不出决定，轰，被吐槽了。
Creed, your teeth call.
Your breath stinks. Boom, roasted.
Angela, where's Angela?
Well, there you are. I didn't see you behind that grain of rice.
Boom. Roasted.
Stanley, you crush your wife during sex and your heart sucks.
Boom, roasted.
Oscar, you are...
克里德，你的牙齿在呼唤。你的口气臭极了。轰，被吐槽了。安吉拉，安吉拉在哪？好吧，你在这儿。我没看见你藏在那粒米饭后面。轰。被吐槽了。斯坦利，你在做爱时压垮了你的妻子，而且你的心脏烂透了。轰，被吐槽了。奥斯卡，你是……
Oscar?
You're gay.
Andy Cornel call. They think you suck.
And you're gay than Oscar.
Oscar. Boom, roast it. Boom, roasting. All right, everybody. You know I kid. You know I kid.
You guys are the reason that I went into the paper business. So, good night. God bless. God bless America.
And get home safe.
How he ends it with what he would have said the night before.
奥斯卡？你是同性恋。安迪·科内尔在呼唤。他们觉得你很逊。而且你比奥斯卡还要弯。奥斯卡。轰，被吐槽了。轰，被吐槽。好了，各位。你知道我是在开玩笑。你知道我是在开玩笑。你们才是我进入造纸行业的动力。所以，晚安。上帝保佑。上帝保佑美国。路上小心。他是怎么用他前一天晚上本会说的话来收尾的。
Yeah. He just fully reads his whole roast.
I thought both Steve and Leslie David Baker did such a great job of building that laugh moment
and that feeling of acceptance and that everything's going to be okay, both of them.
Same.
Well, there were a lot of alts for Michael's roast of the room, in particular for Creed.
These few cracked me up.
是的。他完完整整地读完了他准备的全部吐槽。我觉得史蒂夫和莱斯利·大卫·-贝克在营造那种笑点、那种被接受的感觉以及一切都会好起来的氛围方面都做得太棒了，他们两个都是。我也是。我也是。我也是。好吧，迈克尔对全场众人的吐槽有很多备选台词，特别是针对克里德的。这几条把我笑喷了。
Creed, how about you trim your ear hair once in a while?
Boom, roasted.
Creed, you're so old, you send money to pay.
PBS, boom, roasted.
Creed, at your age, getting lucky is finding your reading glasses.
Bam, Zoom, roasted.
Creed, you're so old and all-nighter means not having to get up to pee.
Boom, roasted.
克里德，你能不能偶尔修剪一下耳毛？轰，被吐槽了。克里德，你太老了，你还给公共广播电台捐款，轰，被吐槽了。克里德，到了你这个年纪，走运就是找到你的老花镜。砰，变焦，被吐槽了。克里德，你太老了，熬夜的意思居然是不需要起床小便。轰，被吐槽了。
And then there were a few for Toby, too, but I just am going to read my favorite.
Ready?
Yes.
Michael would have said, Toby, fuck you.
Boom, roasted.
It was like an all caps.
It's in all caps.
So Michael's roast ultimately is a hit.
然后还有几条是针对托比的，但我只想读我最喜欢的那条。准备好了吗？是的。迈克尔本会说：“托比，去你的。”轰，被吐槽了。就像是全是大写字母。全是大写的。所以迈克尔的吐槽最终大获成功。
He does make Stanley laugh.
And the episode ends with a Michael talking head where he says,
they say that laughter is the best medicine.
So Stanley, you can throw away those pills.
You are cured.
Actually, you should better hold onto them pills just in case.
Well, I thought we should end this special boom-roasted episode with one last candy bag alt.
It's one for Michael.
他确实把斯坦利逗笑了。剧集在迈克尔的一段面对镜头独白中结束，他说：“人们说笑是最好的良药。所以，斯坦利，你可以把那些药片扔了。你已经痊愈了。其实，你最好还是留着那些药片，以防万一。”好吧，我觉得我们应该用最后一个糖果袋备选台词来结束这个特别的“轰，被吐槽了”主题单集。这是给迈克尔准备的。
It's his talking head at the end.
and here's what he would have said.
There's a lot of kinds of laughter.
There's the little chuckle, like when someone tells you a joke.
And it says in parentheses, he chuckles.
There's that uncontrollable giggling, like when your friends just told you an embarrassing secret.
In parentheses, he giggles.
There's the big belly laugh like when you watch a Robin Williams movie.
这是他最后的镜头独白，他是这样说的：“笑有很多种。有轻轻的窃笑，就像有人给你讲笑话时那样。”括号里写着：他窃笑。“有那种无法控制的咯咯笑，就像你的朋友刚告诉你一个尴尬的秘密时那样。”括号里写着：他咯咯笑。“有那种开怀大笑，就像你看一部罗宾·威廉姆斯的电影时那样。”
Michael does a belly laugh.
And then there's a laughter that comes from the heart laughter.
Stanley's heart might have stopped working.
but it kept on laughing.
And I would rather laugh than work.
That's just me.
It's kind of sweet.
Heart laughter.
迈克尔开怀大笑。“然后，还有一种发自内心的笑，心灵的笑。斯坦利的心脏可能停止了跳动，但它一直在笑。我宁愿大笑也不愿工作。这就是我。”这有点甜蜜。心灵的笑。
Lady, you give me heart laughter.
Thank you.
You make me laugh really hard.
Same.
And it's nice.
It's good.
It's healthy.
心灵的笑。蕾迪，你给了我心灵的笑。谢谢你。你把我逗得哈哈大笑。我也是。这很好。很好。很健康。
Yes, very.
And Lee makes me laugh.
I feel so fortunate.
Yeah, Josh really cracks me up.
I mean, in our family, everyone thinks Josh is the funny one.
Like, he's the one that gets us all.
because you don't see it coming.
Well, you know, my kids voted on who was the funniest in our family.
是的，非常健康。而且莉Lee总是能逗我笑。我觉得自己太幸运了。是的，乔希真的把我笑死。我是说，在我们家里，每个人都觉得乔希是那个搞笑的人。就像，他是那个能把我们所有人都逗乐的人，因为你根本预料不到。好吧，你知道的，我的孩子们投票选出了我们家里谁最搞笑。
I came in fifth.
Like, after the pets.
Oh, after the pets?
Well, I guess the only thing I'm funnier than is the dog.
Oh, Maggie's not funny.
I was like, it's such a funny thing to say, though.
It's only how I make my living.
I know.
我排在第五位。就像，排在宠物后面。哦，排在宠物后面？好吧，我猜我唯一比之好笑的只有狗了。哦，玛吉一点都不好笑。我当时想，不过说出这话本身就太搞笑了。这可是我谋生的手段。我知道。
As a comedic actress and podcaster, but whatever.
I know.
Not a big deal. Not funny to my family.
Yeah. Well, Josh is the funny one in my family.
But I think I'm funnier than our animals. I don't know. I haven't asked. Who knows? I'll get back to you.
Let me know. All right. Well, that was really fun. I really loved those candy bag alt.
That was nice. I mean, I spent like a whole day reading them. I know you did too. And it was like, I could hear everyone's voices.
Yeah. And it was so fun. Well, let's take a break. And when we come back, it's time for around
作为一名喜剧女演员和播客主持人，但无所谓。我知道。没什么大不了的。在我家人眼里一点都不好笑。是的。好吧，乔希是我家里搞笑的那一个。但我认为我比我们的动物好笑。我不知道。我还没问。谁知道呢？回头再告诉你。告诉我。好吧。好吧，这真的很有趣。我真的很喜欢那些糖果袋备选台词。太棒了。我是说，我花了一整天时间读它们。我知道你也读了。那种感觉就像，我能听到每个人的声音。是的。太有趣了。好吧，我们休息一下。回来之后，是时候进入
The Town and our office question of the week.
We are back and Sam, we had a few people write in and say, they miss your Around the Town sting.
So I thought we should make sure we play it today.
Absolutely.
Here we go.
Around the Town!
It's so stupid.
It's so perfect.
“走过小镇”以及我们的每周办公室问答环节了。我们回来了，萨姆，有几位听众写信来说，他们很想念你的“走过小镇”音效。所以我觉得我们今天一定要确保把它放出来。绝对的。我们开始吧。走过小镇！太蠢了。太完美了。
I love it so much.
All right.
Let's start with one from our snail mail.
Alice B from Massachusetts wrote in to say,
Ladies, I know you love a fun summer trip, so I wanted to write you about an amazing festival.
My family and I went last year and had a great time.
It's the Revere Beach International Sand Sculpting Festival.
Professional sand sculptors from all over the world come here, and what they do with sand is unbelievable.
我太喜欢了。好吧。让我们从纸质信件开始。来自马萨诸塞州的爱丽丝·B写信说：“女士们，我知道你们喜欢有趣的夏日旅行，所以我想写信向你们推荐一个令人惊叹的节日。我和我的家人去年去过，玩得非常开心。这就是里维尔海滩国际沙雕节。来自世界各地的专业沙雕艺术家都会来到这里，他们用沙子创作出的作品简直令人难以置信。”
True works of art.
Plus, there's great food, lots of entertainment and fireworks, and Revere Beach is easy to get to from Boston.
So if you love the beach and sand castles, this is the one for you.
come visit us in Massachusetts. We love you, ladies. I mean, that sounds cool. I know. It always sounds cool. When can we do this stuff? I think it's after our kids graduate school. I mean, we just have to be here right now. Well, listen, I'm firmly believing office ladies is going to go on forever. We have our back library that's always going to run. And maybe we can just hop on and have some travel journal chats.
Oh, that's a fun idea. Like if we finally get to go to all these things. Yeah, we'll just come in and we'll read,
are journals of going to the Revere Beach International Sand Sculpting Festival.
I would love to hear each of our takes on that.
Me too.
真正的艺术品。另外，那里有很棒的食物、大量的娱乐活动和烟花，而且从波士顿去雷维尔海滩非常方便。所以如果你喜欢海滩和沙堡，这里就是为你准备的。快来马萨诸塞州看看我们吧。我们爱你们，女士们。我的意思是，听起来很酷。我知道。听起来总是那么酷。我们什么时候能做这些事情？我想是在我们孩子们毕业之后。我的意思是，我们现在必须在这里。好吧，听着，我坚信办公室女士们会永远做下去。我们有我们的过往资料库，它将永远运行。也许我们可以直接加入并进行一些旅行日记聊天。哦，那是个有趣的主意。就像如果我们最终能去所有这些地方一样。是的，我们会直接来，然后我们会阅读我们去雷维尔海滩国际沙雕节的日记。我很想听听我们每个人对此的看法。我也是。
And like what we ate, I went to the website, and this festival happens end of July.
The artwork is unbelievable.
Like the sand art is unbelievable.
Alice, you're right.
Lady, I have another place for us to go.
Oh, okay.
We got an around the town from Stephanie D. in Cedar Rapids, Iowa, who says Mount
Trashmore in Cedar Rapids, Iowa is a former landfill with 6 million tons of garbage transformed into a recreation destination with walking and bicycling trails and a scenic overlook of the city.
还有我们吃了什么，我去了网站，这个节日是在七月底举行。艺术品简直难以置信。就像沙雕艺术简直难以置信。爱丽丝，你是对的。女士，我还有另一个地方要带我们去。哦，好吧。我们收到了来自爱荷华州锡达拉皮兹的斯蒂芬妮·D.的“走遍小镇”来信，她说爱荷华州锡达拉皮兹的特拉什莫尔山（Mount Trashmore）是一个前垃圾填埋场，有600万吨垃圾被改造为一个娱乐目的地，有散步和骑自行车小径以及城市的风景俯瞰点。
Stephanie said I am currently working on completing the annual Mount Trashmore Challenge for the second time.
What is that?
Okay.
You can earn prizes and you get your name on the annual challenge plaque if you hit 140 climbs.
of Mount Trashmore because that is the equivalent of Mount Everest.
Wow.
Stephanie said your podcast keeps me positive, smiling, and entertained as I put in another climb
toward my goal.
斯蒂芬妮说我目前正在第二次完成年度特拉什莫尔山挑战赛。那是什么？好吧。如果你完成140次攀登特拉什莫尔山，你可以赢得奖品，并且你的名字会出现在年度挑战牌匾上，因为这相当于珠穆朗玛峰。哇。斯蒂芬妮说，当我为我的目标进行又一次攀登时，你们的播客让我保持积极、微笑和娱乐。
Thank you for keeping me company along the way.
I love that trash has been turned into a community asset that provides individuals an opportunity
to meet new people, get active, and celebrate one another's successes.
Lady, I want to climb Mount Trashmore with you.
I mean, and also, Stephanie, what a positive thing, you know?
Yeah.
Gosh, I love that.
I would climb it with you.
谢谢你们一路上陪伴我。我喜欢垃圾被变成了一个社区资产，它为个人提供了一个结识新朋友、变得活跃并庆祝彼此成功机会。女士，我想和你一起攀登特拉什莫尔山。我的意思是，而且还有，斯蒂芬妮，多么积极的一件事，你知道吗？是的。天哪，我喜欢那样。我愿意和你一起去爬。
Can we climb it one time?
Do we have to climb it 140?
We just go one time.
Okay.
Also, I happen to love Iowa.
I have a little bit of a sweet spot for Iowa because it's right on the border of Missouri,
and we used to go into a tumwa for really good, like, loose meat hamburgers when I was in college.
I've never been to Iowa.
我们能爬一次吗？我们非得爬140次吗？我们只去一次。好吧，另外，我碰巧很喜欢爱荷华州。我对爱荷华州有一点偏爱，因为它就在密苏里州边界上，我在上大学时经常去奥通瓦吃非常美味的，类似于散肉汉堡的东西。我从未去过爱荷华州。
Oh, it's great.
Well, there we go.
Gosh, put it on our list.
I know this what I'm saying.
This list is getting long.
Okay, that's what she said.
Did she say that?
I don't know.
哦，它很棒。好吧，那就这样吧。天哪，把它写进我们的名单。我知道这就是我所说的。这份名单越来越长了。好吧，那是她说的。她说过吗？我不知道。
This list is, no, it's not getting wrong.
I don't think she said it.
If it's getting long, it's growing, guys.
This thing is getting long.
Sam said I will allow it.
You're allowing the...
Hold on.
Go watch yourself, counselor.
这份名单是，不，它没有变错。我不认为她说过。如果它在变长，它在增长，伙计们。这东西越来越长了。萨姆说我允许这样做。你允许……等一下。管好你自己，律师。
Okay.
Oh, boy.
All right.
Michelle E. from New Albany, Indiana,
wrote in and said,
hi office ladies. First off, I wanted to say how much I love your show. Thank you, Michelle. And then Michelle said,
I wanted to share something cool my daughter's school did the other day. They did a wax museum and had to do a
report on famous Hoosiers. She told me that one of her best friends was doing her report on Jenna Fisher.
好吧。哦，天哪。好吧，印第安纳州新奥尔巴尼的米歇尔·E.写信说，嗨，办公室女士们。首先，我想说我多么喜欢你们的节目。谢谢你，米歇尔。然后米歇尔说，我想分享一件我女儿的学校前几天做的酷事。他们办了一个蜡像馆，并且必须做一个关于著名印第安纳人的报告。她告诉我，她的一个好朋友正在做关于珍娜·费舍尔的报告。
I was quick to reply that Jenna was not a Hoosier and she grew up in St. Louis since I feel like I know
so much about you guys. I then discovered, Jenna, you were born in Fort Wayne, which I guess makes
you a Hoosier. There were several girls that did their reports on you since there was more than
one class and maybe not that many famous Hoosiers. But I still thought it was neat and wanted to share.
Thank you again for all you do. Well, it's true, Michelle. I was born in Fort Wayne, Indiana.
My folks grew up in St. Louis, but my dad was transferred there for work. That's where I was born.
I think I lived there less than two years. We moved away when I was pretty little. And I did then grow up in St.
Louis. I've never been back to Fort Wayne. I almost went to college. My second choice school
我很快回复说珍娜不是印第安纳人，她是在圣路易斯长大的，因为我觉得我对你们了解太多了。然后我发现，珍娜，你出生在韦恩堡，我想这让你成了印第安纳人。有几个女孩做了关于你的报告，因为有不止一个班级，也许没有那么多著名的印第安纳人。但我仍然觉得这很 neat 并想分享。再次感谢你们所做的一切。好吧，这是真的，米歇尔。我出生在印第安纳州韦恩堡。我父母在圣路易斯长大，但我爸爸为了工作被调到了那里。那是我出生的地方。我想我在那里住了不到两年。我很小的时候我们就搬走了。然后我确实在圣路易斯长大。我从未回过韦恩堡。我差点去上大学。我的第二选择学校
when I did my college tours was Butler University in Indiana because they had a really good
dance program. And your mom has shared on this show that you and Emily, your sister, were very
good dancers. Yeah. I mean, I knew though, like when I went to visit, I was like, I don't have it
to make this program. So, but I loved the campus. But I've never been back to Fort Wayne. I've kind of
wanted to go. Do you have any memories of Fort Wayne?
Were you that young?
I was young enough that I don't have any memories.
So from Fort Wayne, my family moved to California for about two years.
当我做大学参观时，是印第安纳州的巴特勒大学，因为他们有一个非常好的舞蹈项目。你的妈妈在这个节目中分享过你和你的妹妹艾米丽是非常优秀的舞者。是的。我的意思是，我知道，当我参观时，我想，我没有能力进入这个项目。所以，但我喜欢这个校园。但我从未回过韦恩堡。我有点想去。你对韦恩堡有什么记忆吗？你当时那么年轻吗？我年轻到没有任何记忆。所以从韦恩堡，我的家人搬到了加利福尼亚大约两年。
Do you remember that at all?
I do.
I remember that we had an above ground swimming pool and I would swim in the pool with the dog.
And I remembered that we had a lemon tree and I used to pick the lemons and eat them right off the tree.
Ooh, wow.
So I have two very faint memories of California.
Wait, you can just...
I don't think you're supposed to...
你还记得那个吗？我记得。我记得我们有一个地上游泳池，我会在泳池里和狗一起游泳。我还记得我们有一棵柠檬树，我过去常常摘柠檬，直接从树上吃。哦，哇。所以我对加州有两个非常微弱的记忆。等等，你就可以……我不认为你应该……
You can bite into a lemon lady to the stay?
Can you just eat a lemon like an apple?
No, I mean...
You're creed eating the onion right now.
No, I mean, people do that all the time.
Okay, so you cut the lemon open.
Yeah, and then you like lick it, you squeeze it.
And can you still do that and it doesn't give you the wee G-Bs?
女士，直到今天你还可以咬一口柠檬吗？你可以像吃苹果一样直接吃柠檬吗？不，我的意思是……你现在就在啃洋葱。不，我的意思是，人们经常这样做。好吧，所以你把柠檬切开。是的，然后你舔它，你挤压它。你还能那样做，而且它不会让你感到胃部不适吗？
No, no, no.
I could maybe do that with like a Meyer lemon.
But I guess I just loved lemons.
Oh, I also remember we had snails and I used to take the snails and like put them on my arm.
Those are my memories, snails, lemons, and an above ground pool.
That was my childhood.
All right.
I think it is time for the office question of the week.
不，不，不。我可能可以用迈耶柠檬（Meyer lemon）那样做。但我想我只是喜欢柠檬。哦，我也记得我们有蜗牛，我过去常常把蜗牛拿来放在我的胳膊上。这些就是我的记忆，蜗牛、柠檬和一个地上游泳池。那就是我的童年。好了。我想是时候回答本周的办公室问题了。
This is from Bonnie P. in Kitchener, Ontario.
Hi, Jenna and Angela.
I am currently listening to the episode Dwight K. Shrewt, acting manager.
And I have a question about the office that I have been dying to ask.
Who designed the logo for Dunder Mifflin?
It bears a striking resemblance to the logo of the company that my husband works for.
This company, and by the way, Bonnie, I hope I'm saying this correct.
But Bonnie said the company's name is Malau Blamey Construction.
这是来自安大略省基奇纳的邦妮·P.提出的。嗨，珍娜和安吉拉。我目前正在收听剧集《德怀特·K·施鲁特，代理经理》，我有一个关于办公室的问题一直渴望问。谁为邓德米弗林设计了标志？它与我丈夫工作的公司的标志有着惊人的相似之处。这家公司，顺便说一句，邦妮，我希望我发音正确。但邦妮说公司的名字是马拉乌布雷米建筑公司（Malau Blamey Construction）。
And it was founded in 1982 in Waterloo, Ontario.
So it and the logo has been around for longer than the office.
Is this just a coincidence?
Do a comparison and let me know what you think.
Thank you.
Here's the picture, Bonnie.
All right.
Let's look at this picture.
它于1982年在安大略省滑铁卢成立，所以它和这个标志的存在时间比《办公室》还要长。这只是巧合吗？做一个对比，让我知道你的想法。谢谢。这是照片，邦妮。好吧。让我们看看这张照片。
Well, listen, it is blue.
And it's kind of got that with white framing.
Big letters.
The spacing of the words is close too.
Like they're physically very, very close together.
I mean, I see a similarity.
I'm very curious.
Bonnie, we will do a side by side and put it in our stories,
好吧，听着，它是蓝色的。它有点带有白色边框。大写字母。单词之间的间距也很近。就像它们在物理上非常非常接近一样。我的意思是，我看到了相似之处。我很好奇。邦妮，我们会做一个并排对比并把它放在我们的快拍中，
but I do see the similarity you're talking about.
Yeah, I see the similarity.
I think it's different enough, but it is similar.
I really liked this question because I realized this is something that we have never dug into.
Where did this logo?
this very famous logo that is all over the place now on shirts and on actual reams of paper.
Like, who did design this?
So I reached out to Greg and Greg said the original one would have been in the pilot.
但我确实看到了你所说的相似之处。是的，我看到了相似之处。我认为它足够不同，但它是相似的。我真的很喜欢这个问题，因为我意识到这是我们从未深入探讨过的事情。这个标志在哪里？这个非常著名的标志现在到处都是，在衬衫上和真正的纸张令上。像，究竟是谁设计了这个？所以我联系了格雷格，格雷格说原版应该在试播集中。
Our pilot episode had a different production designer than our longtime production designer Michael Gallenberg.
This was true.
Our DP on the pilot was different from our longtime DP Randall Einhorn, who took over once the show
got picked up. So same with our production designer. The production designer on our pilot was Donald
Lee Harris. And within his department, Henry Sane was credited as the graphic designer. So Greg said
his guess is Henry must have designed it. And he just remembers that Michael Gallenberg made
variations of it for different uses. But Greg said it would be interesting to find out if you can
track down either Donald Lee Harris or Henry Sane and ask because Greg added that at one point,
我们的试播集有一位不同的制作设计师，而不是我们的长期制作设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格。确实如此。我们试播集的主摄影师（DP）不同于我们的长期主摄影师兰德尔·艾恩霍恩，后者在剧集被预订后接手了工作。我们的制作设计师也是如此。我们试播集的制作设计师是唐纳德·李·哈里斯。在他的部门里，亨利·塞恩被署名为平面设计师。所以格雷格说他猜亨利一定设计了它。他只记得迈克尔·加伦伯格为了不同的用途制作了它的变体。但格雷格说，如果能追踪到唐纳德·李·哈里斯或亨利·塞恩并询问将会很有趣，因为格雷格补充说，在某个时候，
he was told that the Dunder Mifflin fictional brand is the second most famous fictional brand after
Duff Beer from The Simpsons. Wow. Mm-hmm. That's crazy. Yeah. Well, Jenna, this also got me curious
about the logo of the BBC version of the office for their company, Wernham Hogg. So I looked it up.
because I couldn't remember it. Me either now that you mention it. Does it look like the Dunder Mifflin one?
Not at all. Look at it. It's totally different. I'll put it in stories. Oh, very different. It's
red and black and yeah. The font's different. It's not framed in any way. It's got like a big W and then
the letters come off that giant W. Yes. Well, I found Henry Sane on IMDB. He directed Bounty Hunter.
He has an extensive resume for graphic design. I was hoping to see if there was like some
有人告诉他，邓德米弗林这个虚构品牌是继《辛普森一家》中的达夫啤酒之后第二著名的虚构品牌。哇。嗯-hmm。太疯狂了。是的。嗯，珍娜，这也让我对BBC版办公室中他们公司的标志产生了好奇，也就是沃恩姆·霍格公司（Wernham Hogg）。所以我查了一下。因为我记不清了。既然你提到了，我也不记得。它看起来像邓德米弗林的那款吗？一点也不。看它。完全不同。我会把它放到快拍里。哦，非常不同。它是红色的和黑色的，是的。字体不同。它没有任何边框。它有一个巨大的W，然后字母从那个巨大的W上延伸出来。是的。嗯，我在IMDB上找到了亨利·塞恩。他导演了《赏金猎人》。他有丰富的平面设计履历。我曾希望看看是否有关于他的某种
trivia about him? I tried to dig around. Like, is there anything attributed to him for having
designed this very famous logo? I couldn't find anything, but I did find some contact information
for his manager, so maybe we can reach out. Matt is on vacation this week. He's high up on a
mountain. So when he's back, maybe we can get to the bottom of it. And Henry, hey, if you're hearing this,
write us. Yes, or anyone who knows Henry or anyone who knows who designed.
this logo. We want to hear from you. All right. Well, this was just a ton of fun. I had such a great time.
I was so excited today coming into work. Josh was like, what are you so chipper about? I was like,
well, I don't know. I just get to go talk with my bus for a room. Yeah. I don't know why I'm saying
琐事？我试图深入挖掘。比如，有什么归功于他设计了这个非常著名的标志吗？我找不到任何东西，但我确实找到了他经纪的一些联系信息，所以也许我们可以联系他。马特这周在度假。他在高高的山上。所以等他回来后，也许我们可以弄清真相。还有亨利，嘿，如果你听到了这个，给我们写信。是的，或者任何认识亨利的人，或者任何知道是谁设计了这个标志的人。我们想听到你的声音。好吧，这真是太有趣了。我度过了一段非常美好的时光。我今天来上班时太兴奋了。乔什问，你为什么这么高兴？我说，嗯，我不知道，我只是要去和我的老相好聊天。是的。我不知道我为什么要
it like that. I don't either. I don't either. But I felt the same way. You know, I'm taking off for my
summer vacation after we record this episode. I know. You're on vacay, lady. I know. So I was sort of
aware, like, oh, it's going to be a couple weeks before I get to see you and record again.
So this was a nice send-off. Thanks. Well, I'm doing a little vacay myself, lady.
You're doing a bucket list vacay. I really am. It is something I've wanted to do. I mean,
my whole life, really. I'm going to Wimbledon, you guys. I'm going to Wimbledon. I can't wait.
And I'm just giddy about it. I think I've sent you like eight pictures of like, what do I wear?
I'm so, so excited for you. I think we need to do a summer travel journal episode. I will share about Lake of the Ozarks and I think you should share about this Wimbledon trip.
那样说。我也不知道。我也不知道。但我有同感。你知道，录完这集后我要去过暑假了。我知道。你在度假，女士。我知道。所以我有点意识到，哦，要过几个星期我才能见到你并再次录音。所以这是一个很好的告别。谢谢。嗯，我自己也在度假，女士。你在进行愿望清单上的度假。我真的是。这是我一直想做的事情。我的意思是，真的，我的一生。我要去温布尔登，伙计们。我要去温布尔登。我等不及了。我为此感到兴奋不已。我想我已经给你发了大约八张照片，问我该穿什么。我为你感到太、太兴奋了。我觉得我们需要做一个夏季旅行日记剧集。我会分享奥沙克湖（Lake of the Ozarks）的事情，我认为你应该分享这次温布尔登之旅。
Okay, done. All right. Well, on that note, everyone, thank you so much. We hope you are also having a great summer and we will be back next week with another episode.
See you then. Boom roasted.
Roasted.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
好吧，一言为定。好吧，就此而言，大家，非常感谢。我们希望你们也过着一个伟大的夏天，我们将在下周带着另一集回归。到时见。轰，烤得好。烤得好。感谢收听办公室女士们。办公室女士们是奥德赛（Audyssey）的一个呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔，我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。奥德赛的执行制作人是利亚·里斯·丹尼斯。办公室女士们的混音和母带制作由比尔·舒尔茨完成。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡皮树》。